the last 24 hours after the apartment
chantal went to the bank
she swiped out all the money that we
have in our young account
and let me without nothing
i went this morning to try to get a
little teens you know from my apartment
and when they tried to swipe the car the
car stayed declining
i said oh that's weird like because i
got my money there and when they got to
the car i opened the banking the
internet backing i noticed the sheep
swiper everything
all the money
two hundred in sixty-five thousand
dollars
she moved i got your shake
she got a check
she walked right now we in her hands
with all that money
i've been working hard for that money
and she took it she took it like he like
it
it's her money and you know what she
told me one day she told me one day like
if you divorce me you have to pay me
because i bring you to the rest day and
maybe
maybe she's got to get her payment
[Music]
hey
okay
[Music]
is
i want to be fair all the time this is
my team it's only going to be fair
i want my power she get the girl half we
can sell the house she can take her half
but you go that that way that round like
that so low
having worked i had no planning on the
contract right now doesn't mean that i
need to i need to wait like one month or
two months you know for me making money
again because she made my life
impossible to work impossible to do
anything
[Music]